good morning Hank it's Tuesday I'm
actually at a mini golf course I wish
you were here but you're busy like
interviewing the president or whatever
oh wait
I'm in Florida where this happens it's
question Tuesday the day that we answer
real questions from real nerdfighters
while also playing mini golf are you
nervous about interviewing the President
of the United States thanks for bringing
it up are you yes I'm trying to go but
is it going to affect your golfing
absolutely oh oh that was terrible how
do you look so much taller than me it
must be because there's something wrong
with the ground anyway what's your
favorite flight was bird you're my
favorite brother
Hank she's got a hole in one but I
insisted that he tapped it twice because
I don't want to get too far behind and
I'm the big brother and that's how we
compete I may not be better than you
Hank but I am able to change the rules
midstream are you behind me what are you
nothing there's a ton of waterfalls in
this joint if your math name or any
other color what would it be
Oh shark fruits I would go with blue
which i think is a kind of chartreuse
the next question is will you try on
each other's glasses and I think we
should do that and putt-putt ooh
thanks for Scripture it's actually
pretty close to mine I feel fairly
comfortable yours are just mostly dirty
oh my god John I don't clean my glasses
very often but that's just disgusting
can he perform under the pressure of
wearing his brother's glasses
it's Hank green it's a green Oh No
there it is what a girder
oh come on give me that damn that's a
good bounce between the two of us who
was weirder in high school oh I don't
know me
I feel like me you want all those
friends who's better at rhyming I don't
know but I have pretty good timing so I
was trying to think of a rhyme for
timing that didn't get there diming
climbing climbing glide took me a minute
hang might be better we should remember
of one direction let's go with the
police officer guy I like the
construction worker yeah now okay
they're all good though I love that song
yeah uh MCA it's fun to stay at the YMCA
eh what should win the Oscar for Best
Picture with The Fault in Our
Stars job not nominated um I'm gonna go
like the 50s clouds right now guy no
it's all marketing never not marketing
so I'm gonna go with whiplash or Selma I
thought but both those were excellent
Hank how do you feel about koalas they
poop in their sleep
is that true can you play the ukulele no
yes I can by the two chords I can't play
it at all and what's your favorite type
of hummus a chickpea I didn't know there
were types of hummus it's a final hole
and we are tied
oh it's tense very tense eighteen take
is significantly closer than I am for
the tie
No Oh No how does it feel to be less
good than me I'll see you on Friday